Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we get this question asked a lot and it
is, can I purchase a programmed rife machine?
Honestly, that's a big reason why a lot of people search for us on the web is because
of my experience using rife technology.
It all started back in the late 90s, so do the math on how many years that is because you're
watching this video.
And yes, we do sell programmed rife machines.
We don't just sell rife machines, but we sell them programmed.
Now most of the programmed rife machines are sold to people who come on as a comprehensive
member to be honest, but we do allow some people after a case review.
So a case review is where it all starts, so you can't just go online and add our store
and buy a programmed rife machine without talking to me.
So because quite honestly, I don't think a rife machine is a magic wand for everybody
to be healed of every disease or anything like that.
I don't, I just don't believe that.
I think there's tools that are out there as me as a practitioner have used over all the
years that I've been in practice since 1986.
There's tools that are used for different things.
We use cold lasers for musculoskeletal injuries.
We use PEMFs for increasing your body's charge that can help with immune system.
It can help with inflammation.
We've used tons of different apparatuses, tons of different machines that are good for a lot
of things.
Now I got started with rife technology because a person with cancer came to me and that's
what I thought rife machines were for was for cancer.
Well, they certainly are, but they're for a lot of other things.
They can kill pathogens.
They're great for Lyme disease.
They're great for chronic infections, Epstein-Mar issues.
So it can be great for everybody in the family.
It's great if your kid's got a bad cold or you feel like you're coming down with a flu.
A rife machine is a great tool for that.
Let's say if I just have heavy metal toxicity, that's my only problem, like it could possibly
exist.
Would a rife machine be the best tool?
Probably not.
I mean, using the ion pro wave apparatus on the rife machine that I'll show you in a second
can be really helpful.
So I do think it would be beneficial for every person to have a rife machine in their
home, but you would use it for everything.
So what rife machines do we use?
So we use two different rife machines.
I've used true rife for years.
I've used other ones before I started using true rife that I don't use anymore.
The Lyme generator is one.
There's several other than I can't remember the name of.
I think GB4000 are decent machines too, but we don't sell those.
So we sell the Atelier Robin P220, which I think is probably the most powerful machine
on the market now.
That's a newly developed machine.
And I think the true rife are good machines, are great machines too.
I've used to true rife for, I don't know, 15 years, and we've had much success with
that.
So most people that have purchased a rife machine from me in the past got a true rife.
So, but I will decide for you in a way, I'll at least talk you through my rationale.
When I talk to you on a case review, what will be the best machine for you?
So I've always said that I am not married to a company.
I don't have any financial interest in either one of these two companies, nor any other company
in order to make my recommendations.
So I get to recommend what I think is the best machine on the market.
And if I always say that the new machine comes on the market, then I think it's better, always
it has to be what is the best interest of the patient.
So I will help you walk through that decision-making process.
Now with the rife machine comes some other apparatuses.
One is the ion pro-wave.
So the ion pro-wave will look like one of these two apparatuses on your lower screen here.
The one on the left is the one for the atelier Robin.
It has some benefits over the true rife's ion pro-wave.
The benefits are it's easy to change the plates yourself, it's easy to unscrew that, those
little nylon screws, and you can change the plate because you will burn through plates.
And when you use the ion pro-wave after about 40, 50, 60 sessions.
And with the atelier Robin, it's easy to change the plate yourself, it's far less expensive.
The true rife's ion pro-wave comes more compact, you know, sense that it looks a little prettier.
It's just different uses.
So ion pro-wave can be a great detoxifying tool.
Here's a picture of a typical ion pro-wave.
This is the one with the atelier Robin P2P220 unit, ion pro-wave, it can pull a lot of junk
out of your body.
But mainly we're using the rife, especially with cancer patients, we're using the bulb.
And I'm writing overnight programs.
So the treatment, tube, plasma, tube, bulb, this seat of this picture, we also include
a ground-dead sheet.
But we build a package, depending upon what is the needs of the person.
With everybody who does our comprehensive program or just purchases the rife from us, they
get what's called our frequency healing course.
I've actually created a course online.
So my worst thought is that a person has a rife machine, worst would be they bought it
from us.
And if they're not using it, that makes me sad.
You know, so it's like buying a treadmill and not using it.
Well, I've been guilty of that, right?
But I certainly don't want you buying a piece of therapy equipment that can be highly beneficial
for you and your family and then it's in your closet.
That would really make me sad.
So I put together a course called the frequency healing course.
And I'm adding to it, you know, adding new things to it all the time, with how to use your
rife machine.
Now, we've had some people disappointed in the course that bought the course and didn't have
a rife machine, and they thought, well, this is just a kind of a sales job for a rife
machine.
Well, no, it's really a course educating people to have a rife machine, how to use it, how
to use it for your family, how to use it for cancer, how to use it for a live disease.
I want you to be able to use this wonderful tool.
So it is a wonderful tool, not shown on here as the computer that goes with it, but the
computer contains the program.
And like every wonderful tool, it's, it's, it's using it properly, that'll give you the
best results.
So when I say, you know, I asked this question, can I purchase a rife machine, it's can I purchase
a program rife machine?
You've heard me say that several times, it is the program that makes the difference.
So all my running the right program, I've had people come to me and say, I'm tried rife
and it didn't work.
What were you doing?
I was going to a doctor's office twice a week and running an hour long program for general
cancer, and I, my prostate cancer did not improve at all.
So first of all, number one, a rife machine has to have enough power to penetrate your
body.
There's a lot of rife machines on the market that call themselves a rife machine.
There's no legal entity that says you can't call yourself, you know, a rife dealer or making
rife machines, and it has to be certain specs.
So you have to talk to somebody that you're using a machine that has the specs that it has
the power to penetrate your body.
That's number one.
Number two, you have to run the right frequency.
So if I'm just running general cancer frequencies and I have prostate cancer, it may or may not
affect my prostate cancer.
So if you're not running the right frequencies, well, it's not going to do anything for you.
So you're going to be running the right program that's for you.
That's why I write personalized programs for people.
That's to me the most, if you're going to spend the time sitting there on the rife machine,
you've got to be running the right program.
And then number three, you got to make it easy for a person to be able to use.
So is this usable for the person?
So with the rife machine that we sell, we have to do a case for it first.
We have to talk to you and see what your issue is.
Maybe it's not cancer.
Maybe you have an autoimmune issue.
Well, then I'm going to program it very different.
I have, I personally believe in using a tool if you could at night while you sleep.
So most of the programs that I write are overnight programs.
And it just, it just lends towards my philosophy of, I don't want you living your life sitting
in front of this rife machine.
I understand if you're really sick, some my cancer patients have to sit in front of the rife
machine all day long because they just don't feel well enough to get up anyhow.
So they're already laying in a bed or sitting in the chair and they're resting to try to
recover.
Run the rife machine all the time you possibly can.
But certainly if you're ambulatory, you're up and about to live in your life.
That's why you want to be healthiest so you can be up and about to live in your life.
So our philosophy stems from that that our purpose is to go fulfill God's mission and in doing
so while you sleep, everybody's going to sleep, we might just get the treatment done while
we sleep.
So I write overnight programs.
So overnight programs for 80, 80, 80 HD for anxiety disorders for autoimmune issues and
certainly for cancer and live and all these other diseases that we tend to take care of.
All my cancer members have an overnight program that they're running and then they typically
give some day programs too that they can run during the day when there are, you know, taking
a break or watching TV or reading a book.
But the rife comes with a lot of different programs for a lot of different things because
again, I want you to use this for your family too.
So maybe you have cancer, but now your little one has come down with like a, I think they
got the flu.
We'll run the, you know, cold and flu on coming program to help with that.
I mean, there's just a lot of different programs that you could run for a lot of different
things.
So it's a tool that you want to use.
That's a whole purpose.
So that's my kind of staff who about some other rife machines out there, they're very difficult
to use.
They're very difficult to program.
Well, this is the ones we sell art.
So we want you to be able to use this tool.
So it means defining the benefits of a rife machine.
It has to have the power to penetrate it has to be using light frequency.
It has to be able to be programmable both for the person has to be able to be user friendly
so that the person is using it.
And again, I like to write night programs for the person so they're using it at night
while they sleep.
And then it has the detox function so that you can detox with the in pro wave and the nice
thing about the until your Robin P 220, it has a built in scanner so you can actually learn
how to scan yourself and videos on that and our rife course on how to do that.
I don't want you to be dependent on me.
I want you to have a tool that you can, you know, we're moving into an age of this country
where the more you can have at home to protect yourself against crazy pathogens that may be
facing is to have a tool like this so that you can be best prepared to protect your family.
So again, the way to get started is, you know, go to our website and, you know, see in a
different page of our website, there's a schedule now, but then you hit that and you
go to where you can self schedule a case review.
So if you're not a patient of ours, you're never, this is all new to you.
You can, first of all, I'd recommend if this is all new to you, spend a whole bunch of
time on our website.
Okay.
I have thousands of blog posts, most of them with videos, explaining tons of different health
conditions and natural approaches to life and, you know, again, we see our, our mission
as a ministry.
So our desire is to give as much as we possibly can.
Yeah, we have bills to pay, we can't give everything away, but we try to give as much away
as we possibly can.
Download my books, join my courses, they're super cheap, learn about how to self care, learn
how to take care of yourself.
If you want to move forward with something like this or, or just other health conditions,
maybe you're not interested in a right yet, you're interested in other things, schedule
a case review with me, self schedule online, or call the clinic, and, and we'll talk about
what's going on.
And I may recommend something completely different.
So, but I'll probably, I'll be honest with you.
So most of our patients come out as a comprehensive, especially our cancer patients come out as
a comprehensive, uh, member, the right for sheet is included with that, but not everybody
does.
So I understand that.
So start where you need to start and my motto has been for years, never stop asking why,
why do I have this?
Why do I have cancer?
Why do I have this live disease?
Why can't I get rid of this?
What am I supposed to do?
What's the cause?
There's lots of underlining, cold morbidity causes that many times doctors haven't run
lambs enough to find those things, or they haven't used tools like the right for sheet
to help knock these things out, and I can't say that I can, you know, but I can be praying
for wisdom, you know, to be able to help you, and we cherish your prayers for us as well.
So regardless of what you choose to do, no one will be praying for you.
If you want to move forward, I gave you the steps to do so, and I hope to talk to you
soon.
Bye.